let's talk about the chappelle thing
yeah um hit piece
another hit piece another hit piece uh
if you guys actually believe that dave
chappelle killed uh housing development
because there was affordable housing
attached to it
you are out of your goddamn mind um
there's no in hell impossible uh if
you've seen the video maybe you haven't
even seen the video maybe you just saw
the headline uh he was against this
development yes but it's very important
to note and this was not included in the
headline or many of the pieces that he
was also against the initial development
that did not have the affordable housing
part in it correct that affordable
housing part was added afterwards after
chappelle and many other people in the
community push back on the development
because they didn't like uh the fact
that there was like a garbage dump in
the middle of it there was uh there was
about traffic flow concerned about
traffic flow and water usage like there
was a lot of problems with development
and what often times these corporations
do is they uh they'll add something
really
adorable yeah uh and almost virtuous to
a development to make you side with it
yes or to make you look bad if you
disagree with it if you disagree with it
and and this is the same thing that
happens with like bills in congress
right
exactly you brought that up the patriot
act so explain what happened with the
paper patriarch is basically a law that
lets the government spy on everything
you're doing but they call it the
patriot act so if you disagree with it
you're not a patriarch and it's right
after 9 11 all you want to do is be a
patriot 100 you can't be the congressman
that said no to the patriots exactly
because most people aren't even going to
look into the bill no they're not going
to look and says this can this means we
have freedom to spy on everything that
you do 100 they're just going to see the
headline akash saying vetoes patriot act
how dare he this guy must not love
america don't love america at all and uh
so that's basically what they did i
wouldn't be surprised if the developers
like pr system actually put out the
video 100 chapelle shutting it down um
but this is what he wanted and also what
the community wanted correct he's
speaking on behalf of his people which
is the community in this case but the
media latched on to it i think also
because it's like oh here's a guy who's
not he's kind of easy to take down
because he's being seen as transphobic
he's been seeing such a problem so not
pc so let's just put this out there and
uh we'll write in the article about
liberal nimbyism which is not in my
backyard isn't it like i'll help people
but not if it's close to me and then you
just get to take shots at him over and
over in reality none of that is true and
if you look at the people who
retweeted this or the people who wrote
these articles
it tells you everything about how they
feel about chappelle yeah it tells you a
lot more about the person retweeting
than chappelle yes they're already
looking for a reason to criticize
chappelle
and this headline gave them the perfect
reason to do it if they didn't look into
this correct
now to be fair there wasn't a lot of
information on this like we really had
to do some digging to find out exactly
what happened but
i just can't fat i mean can you guys
fathom that chappelle would knowingly on
video
shut down an affordable housing plant
yeah he's a thoughtful dude that's like
extremely aware of optics he's not just
going to go on in front of cam and just
like make himself look stupid yeah he's
too smart for that and that's how you
know people have an agenda when you're
already attacking somebody before any
knowledge on the 100 so expose so if i'm
him i'm looking at everybody that's
reposted retweeted
ran another version of the article
without looking into it or he's or
either like reaching out for uh to him
for comment or whatever i'm looking at
every single person he probably is you
think i think i mean if i'm him i'm like
i'm like oh you guys are certifiable my
haters yeah right here i know the the
the journalists
the publications and just the random
like twitter celebs yeah like you guys
that are reposting y'all don't want me
to win now i know
loki
if i was him
i might drop it myself
just to see who the haters are
knowing full well you're clean and when
the truth comes out you just exposed
everybody out there who you might have
thought was the homie anyone that's not
going to give you the benefit of the
doubt
yeah
oh you don't see the best of me
that's interesting
nfl gm it did something similar there's
a bunch of leaks so he had the first
pick in the draft for the browns and he
told a bunch of different people
different people he was going to draft
and then whoever whoever player got
leaked oh they're going to draft this
guy first he knew he knew exactly who he
told that guy and he was like there's a
leak right there get rid of that guy
fire move that's some tyrion [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah that's right
that is yeah that's [ __ ] genius um
yeah so yeah so this is uh
let dave off the hook for this this is
put out by the developer though i think
put out by the developer 100 yeah
because they want the pr on their side
so they can move forward with their
[ __ ] bill that happens to and i
think you've said this uh one day there
might be affordable it's not they're not
even guaranteeing affordable housing
it's a plan to one day maybe build it
yes
1.75 acres yeah like maybe if they and
it was a very small but it was like two
percent or three percent of the total
development that was going to be
dedicated to that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
and it worked yeah for a day yeah but
luckily people look into it and then
they can expose it and i think that's
why it's important we talk about these
things now that being said i would love
to see uh
uh chappelle be this passionate about
the the rogan hippies yeah that hurt me
man that would that bum me a little bit
because they're supposed to be homies i
feel like if that's your homie and you
know this man
and he wrote for you oh you owe him that
you owe him i know this guy y'all can
say what the [ __ ] you want but i know
this guy yeah and he had my back because
he knew me yeah
that i've been googling you guys did
arenas together son i keep googling
chappelle and rogan and the thing that
keeps popping up is rogan defending
chappelle and not the other way around
and yo and we've got to give some credit
because don l put out donnell did y'all
i mean shout outs to donnell like
especially being a black dude coming out
in that time right there yeah
i mean that's brave man yeah 100 that's
super [ __ ] up
like he doesn't really tweet that much
yeah but he yeah maybe maybe he's doing
it on stage maybe he puts out something
that he normally puts out a piece write
an op-ed he's incredibly thoughtful and
he can usually he can communicate better
than most people on the [ __ ] plane
so just write an op-ed or just put it on
your instagram you have an instagram
page
you can literally just type something on
a note and then just post there are ways
to do it that's not the issue it's not
like i really want to do this but i
can't there are many ways where a guy
that's as famous as dave chabelle can
communicate his support to a friend of
his right and and he has a podcast
that's right he has a podcast oh yeah i
don't know i haven't listened but maybe
maybe he did talk about it on and i'm
not exactly sure but like in that moment
it would have been
really helpful yeah i think for joe and
if somebody that you know you've done
business with and
has
i mean you've both really had your back
yeah he's had your back that's all i'm
saying is like when you were going
through that time in your life he was on
his podcast biggest platform in the
world riding hard for you yes and you
know this man you guys have spent like
extensive amount of time together and in
the same way you remember the people who
jumped to [ __ ] on you if you put out
that tweet let's say or like when that
thing comes out that video you remember
the [ __ ] who didn't have your
back you also got to remember the
[ __ ] who did have your back in
your darkest moments
and this is joe's darkest moment 100
100 percent is there still time
[Laughter]
so guys
there was one moment i was [ __ ] dying
laughing some [ __ ] people told me after
so i was dying laughing they're
discussing what happened to joe and at
one point akash said it's like yeah you
know as comics we got to look out for
one another he goes you know andrew
always says ape shall not kill ape and
he just
he didn't even think about the
connections not racist yellow guy
god i can't help it i'm the least racist
guy oh my god that's crazy think about
these shits man you react at all did you
say anything no i don't think so no it's
just too many
guys having a conversation not even
thinking about these things bro all
right thank god for spotify's rewind
button but cause i was hitting go back
10 seconds multiple times on that one
right there
unbelievable and he put it on youtube
andrew always says you could say caesar
[ __ ]
[Applause]